you've said that there would never be
any kind of deal that would potentially
cede territory to russia how realistic
is that when you look at
an area of land the size of crimea for
example
an area of land that in order to take
control back of it militarily would
involve potentially billions more
dollars worth of western weapons and
thousands of lives
any surrender of ukrainian territory
would mean the war will continue with
greater intensity and on an even greater
scale you should not see russia as an
honest negotiating partner and sign
legal agreements with it believing it
will be credible and honored in two or
three years russia is expansionist so it
exists only by attacking other states it
attacks in various ways using its energy
resources its military migration using
food as a weapon ukraine can never sign
a deal with russia in this context
therefore the president clearly asked
western partners to participate in this
war because ukraine doesn't have the
military sources that russia has we want
to finish this war the right way
and that means liberating our
territories in full and re-establishing
our sovereignty with an internationally
recognized borders
do you believe everything that western
leaders like president macron like olaf
schultz for example say
giving you
certainly in rhetoric wholehearted
support when you look at the facts
we're looking potentially at a global
recession a global food crisis rising
inflation
huge challenges with gas supplies to
europe in winter
how long do you honestly think that the
europeans can continue this level of
support
some countries living standards are
dropping because of the situation in
ukraine but this is an all-out war and
it's happening on european territory so
of course some living standards are
decreasing because europeans are
indirectly involved in this war they are
paying for the expenses of this war i
understand they want to preserve their
pre-war life and comforts and nobody
wants bad news but if russia gains more
territory it will think its tactics and
strategy of humiliating other countries
works
and it will continue blackmailing europe
what do you say to eu countries who say
that you are not yet ready for eu
candidacy status
yes
there are values that are worth living
for and ukraine is proving on the
battlefield that these values cost lives
they are european values
secondly i don't understand why eu
candidacy cannot be seen as an
opportunity for ukraine to make the
reforms we need for membership
unfortunately not every country
understands this and is unnecessarily
speculating that ukraine is not ready
europe is important for ukraine and that
works both ways